[Music]
I think there's basically no chance that
core we've survived another generation I
think that we're looking at the total
extinction of that of those biospheres
by 2050 or so there are some scientists
who think there's some hope and there
have been some coral reefs that have
recovered but the impacts are so fast
and so catastrophic and we're so far
from really changing course on carbon
it's hard for me to imagine them that
they endure which means that the trips
that we're now taking now to view those
will be taking really on the brink of
mass extinctions and it's important to
keep in mind that globally we are living
already through mass extinction the
World Wildlife Fund says that 60% of all
vertebrate mammals have died since just
1916 70 there have been studies that say
that insect populations may have fallen
by as much as 75 percent over the last
few decades animals are dying globally
at rates never before seen in planetary
history and we are living through that
and imposing those imposing those costs
on the planet ourselves the ocean is a
particularly vulnerable system it's not
just the coral reefs it's also the
circular circulation patterns it's fish
populations and it happens we're also
polluting the oceans with enormous
amounts of plastic which are really
damaging I think those people who really
love the oceans should be quite
terrified I think these ecosystems will
be transformed really dramatically very
quickly so that you know populations of
fishermen that lived for decades on a
particular fish community offshore will
now have to find an entirely different
way of life because those fish will be
swimming in totally different waters and
that is true at every level of the ocean
ecosystem the suffering there is not
going to be any different than the
suffering on land or the suffering
experienced by humans it will be quite
catastrophic if we don't radically
change course very very quickly and this
is in part because the oceans do a lot
to absorb warming so the impacts are
felt most intensely there if it were not
for oceans the planet would probably be
already several degrees warmer than it
is but so much of the additional heat
that we've been
we've been hot housing the planet with
over the last few decades has been taken
up by the ocean and that means that the
ocean has been totally transformed by
that temperature
[Music]